Aujourd'hui nous allons parler du programme d'un candidat dont vous avez peut être entendu parler dans les médias,
Emmanuel Macron.
Son objectif est plutôt simple, redonner à chaque française et français confiance.
En eux,
En la France, et en notre capacité collective à relever nos défis.
Tout ça passe par plusieurs chantiers,
l'éducation et la culture,
la société du travail, la modérnisation de l'économie, la sécurité de la nation, et enfin le renouveau démocratique et l'engagement international .
C'est le point principal du programme d'Emmanuel Macron et ça passe par un plan d'investissement de 50 milliards d'euros , qu'il veut mettre au service de la
qualification des citoyens,
transition écologique,
révolution numérique,
modérnisation des services publiques
et rénovation urbaine .
Pour relancer l'économie,
Emmanuel Macron souhaite simplifier.
Deja pour les entrepeneurs, en supprimant le régime social indépendant, donc le RSI,
et en réduisant les charges.
Ensuite plus globalement pour les indépendants, en laissant aux artisans et commerçants, le choix d'opter pour le régime fiscale de la micro entreprise.
Ensuite,
d'un côté, au niveau des employeurs,
il réduit les cotisations sociales pour faciliter l'embauche,
et de l'autre côté, au niveau des salariés
il crée un bonus malus sur l'assurance chômage
ce qui fait payer plus de charges aux employeurs, qui abusent des contrats courts.
Pour ce qui est de l'impôt, il le simplifie aussi
en mettant l'impôt sur les sociétés à 25%,
en transformant l'ISF, en impôt sur la fortune immobilière,
et en créant un prélèvement unique de 30% sur les revenus du capital.
C'est a dire les revenus liés à la rente, genre immobilières mais aussi financières.
En ce qui concerne le dialogue social,
les principes fondamentaux, comme les 35 heures ou le SMIC,
restent dans la loi,
mais il souhaite quand même que l'organisation du travail ou des horaires,
puissent être négociés dans chaque société
par un accord majoritaire
ou suite a un référendum d'entreprise.
Et enfin, pour ce qui est de la lutte contre la fraude fiscale et sociale, il la renforce et impose les grands groupes de l'internet,
sur leurs chiffre d'affaires
réalisé sur notre sol.
Emmanuel Macron souhaite faire de la lutte contre la discrimination, une priorité nationale, en multipliant les contrôles aléatoires à grandes échelles,
que ce soit pour l'emploi,
ou l'accès au logement
et en publiant les noms des entreprises qui ne respectent pas l'égalité salariale entre les femmes et les hommes.
Il souhaite aussi modifier la relation que les français ont aujourd'hui avec le chômage.
L'idée c'est que même les salariés qui démissionnent,
puissent en bénéficier,
une fois tout les 5 ans,
mais aussi les artisans, indépendants, entrepreneurs, agriculteurs
ou professions libérale.
La contrepartie étant que le refus d'un certain nombre d'offres entraîne l'arrêt des allocations.
Pour les retraites, il veut mettre fin aux injustices des différents régimes existants,
l'idée étant que pour chaque euro cotisé, tout le monde ait le droit à la même pension
il ne souhaite d'ailleurs pas retoucher l'âge de départ a la retraite, ni le montant des pensions.
Emmanuel Macron souhaite recruter 10 000 policiers et gendarmes supplémentaires, pour mettre  en place une police de sécurité quotidienne.
Il souhaite aussi donner aux policiers,
un nouveau pouvoir,
sous le contrôle d'un juge,
celui d'interdire à un délinquant, l'accès à un quartier ou il a commis un délit.
Et déclare la politique de tolérance zéro, contre les incivilités du quotidien qui pourront être punissables d'amendes immédiates et dissuasives.
Par ailleurs, toute peine désormais prononcée, devra être exécutée.
Et comme il est dans une logique d'innovation, il souhaite aussi imposer cyber défense et cyber sécurité,
comme priorité.
Emmanuel Macron veut diviser par 2 le nombre de jours de pollution atmosphérique.
Pour cela, il propose une prime de mille euros pour inciter les citoyens qui ont un véhicule polluant, à en changer,
il souhaite aussi faire de la France, le leader mondial de la recherche sur la transition environnementale,
et dans la lutte contre les pesticides et perturbateurs endocriniens,
qui sont pour lui, l'une des principales causes de l'augmentation des cancers des enfants.
il souhaite aussi d'ici à 2022 que 50% des produits proposés par les cantines scolaires et les restaurants d'entreprise, soient bio, écologiques ou issus de circuits courts.
Pour protéger l'Europe, il souhaite réserver l'accès aux marchés publics européens aux entreprises qui localisent au moins la moitié de leur production,
en Europe dans le cadre d'un "Buy European Act", ainsi que la mise en place d'un mécanisme de contrôle des investissements étrangers en Europe,
pour pouvoir préserver les secteurs stratégiques.
Par ailleurs, il souhaite une lutte accentuée contre les arrangements fiscaux entre les pays européens et les multinationales,
comme cela à pu avoir lieu entre Apple et l'Irlande.
Emmanuel Macron est partisan d'une grande loi de moralisation de la vie publique,
et il y a du boulot ...
L'idée, c'est d'interdire aux parlementaires des activités de conseil à coté de leurs mandats, pour éviter les conflits d'intérêts,
imposer l'intégralité de leurs indemnités,
et la suppression de leur régime spécial de retraite, dont on a eu l'occasion de parler ensemble,
dans un précédent épisode .
L'interdiction de toute embauche, par un élu ou un ministre d'un membre de sa famille.
L'interdiction du cumul de plus de 3 mandats identiques successifs,
l'interdiction, pour tous les détenteurs d'un casier judiciaire niveau B2,
de se présenter à une élection
et la présentation
par le Président de la République,
de son bilan national et européen, une fois par an, devant le Congrès.
Enfin, il souhaite impliquer plus les citoyens, en demandant aux parlementaires de mettre en place des dispositifs innovants d'évaluation du travail parlementaire,
et législatif.
Jurys citoyens, compte rendu de mandat via les réseaux sociaux etc ...
Toute en encourageant les communes à développer  les budgets participatifs,
c'est à dire à consulter directement les citoyens,
sur l'utilisation de l'argent public.
Comme d'habitudes dans les sources, le lien vers son programme complet et comme d'habitude je vous invite à le consulter.
Parce qu'en 5 minutes, on passe forcément à coté de certains points.
On se retrouve très vite pour le, ou les prochains candidats, j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu, n'hésiter pas à la partager si c'est le cas.
Retrouver aussi des décryptage sur la chaîne de l'ami Hugo Décrypte .
Merci à tous les tipeurs, pour soutenir financièrement le projet,
on se revoit bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo,
Love
Peace